bueno lo que quiero ver en este vídeo
son ecuaciones cuadráticas o expresiones
cuadráticas que vamos a factorizar pero
que no tengan como primer término x
cuadrada a secas lo que quiero es que no
tenga un 1 multiplicando álex cuadrada
que tenga otro número multiplicando a la
x cuadrado por ejemplo este 4x cuadrada
más 25 x menos 21 si te das cuenta el
número que está al lado de la x cuadrada
no es 1 como lo habíamos visto en las
ocasiones anteriores es 4 y bueno como
se resuelve esto la forma de resolver
esto es buscar otra vez dos números pero
dos números que cumplan lo siguiente que
la multiplicación de ambos nos den 4 x
menos 21 es decir a por ser el primer
coeficiente por el último coeficiente o
siente sencillamente acuérdate de que es
el número que esté al lado de la equis
por el coeficiente libre y me va a
quedar 4 x menos 21 la multiplicación de
esos dos números me tienen que dar esta
multiplicación que tengo que calcular y
después la suma de estos dos números me
tienen que dar 25
por b es igual a 4 x menos 21 4 por
menos 21 que por cierto 4 por lo menos
21 menos 84 y además a más b me tienen
que dar 25 a más b tiene que ser igual
al término al coeficiente perdón que
está al lado de la x es decir 25 y bueno
quiénes son estos dos números que
cumplen esto si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos al 4 aquí tenemos el 21 esto es
lo que nunca tienes que olvidar tenemos
que multiplicar estos dos de aquí y
bueno bien números me dan que su suma es
25 y que su multiplicación es menos 84
lo primero que podrás decir es que
funciona con 4 y 21 sin embargo tiene
que ser uno positivo y uno negativo y 4
menos 21 me da menos 17 y 21 menos 4
medias 17 por lo tanto no funciona
entonces tenemos que buscar o pensar en
otro par de números tales que sean una
factorización de 84 y que su suma me den
25 y además fíjate como el 84 negativo
tiene que ser uno positivo y uno
negativo
entonces 184 1 y 84 no funciona porque
84 menos unos 83 y por lo tanto esto
nunca me va a dar a 25 bueno 2 y 42 12
42 y los restos me dan o menos 40 ó 40
positivo por lo tanto creo que tampoco
es la mejor opción a ver vamos a ver con
33 y cuántos 84 entre 33 entre 8 me
sobran dos a ver déjenme ver aquí 84
entre 32 veces y dos por tres son 6
entonces le quito 6 me queda 2 y después
bajó el 4 y 24 cabe 8 veces en 38 por 3
24 por lo tanto es 3 y 28 y 28 menos 13
es 25 perfecto aquí están 28 menos 33 25
o 3 menos 28 me da menos 25 pero como yo
quiero que el 25 sea positivo entonces
el 28 tiene que ser positivo y el 3
tiene que ser negativo y ya encontré
estos dos números que estoy buscando y
para que los estoy buscando porque
fíjate voy a escribir el término que
está justo aquí en medio es de 25 x
como menos 3x más 28 x pero antes me
quiero fijar un poquito en que se parece
más 28 a 4 o 28 a 21 fíjate me lo voy a
escribir como 28 x menos 3x y después
voy a poner los términos que me faltan
este de aquí es 25 x 28 x menos 3 x es
lo mismo que 25 x y aquí tengo 4 x
cuadrada y aquí al final tengo menos 21
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que yo
puse el 28 x pegado al 4x cuadrada
porque el 28 x se parece más al 4x
cuadrada que lo que se parece el menos
3x y de hecho el menos 3x se parece más
al menos 21 sino que se parece el 28 x
lo que estoy intentando es que se cuente
en términos muy parecidos con términos
muy parecidos porque lo que voy a hacer
a continuación es factorizar de estos
dos lo más que se pueda es decir de 4x
cuadrada menos 28 x voy a factorizar lo
más que se pueda y por otra parte de los
otros dos también voy a factorizar lo
más que se pueda es decir
3x 21 y de estos 2 voy a tratar de
factorizar todo lo que sea necesario y
vuelvo a repetirte fíjate que el 28
tiene más propiedades en común que el 4
es decir el 28 es divisible entre 4 que
es lo que es el 3 si yo pusiera que 4x
cuadrada menos 3x no se ve tan fácil de
factorizar todo lo que se pueda y de
igual manera para menos 3 y menos 21 - 3
- 21 tienen un factor común y por lo
tanto se puede factorizar bueno entonces
de los dos primeros términos voy a
factorizar lo más que se puede lo más
que se puede es 4 x 4 x que multiplica x
me da 4 x cuadrada y después 28 x entre
4 x 7 ó 4 x x 7 medal 28 x entonces ya
factor hice lo más que se puede y de
aquí lo más que se puede entre menos 3 x
y menos 21 es un menos 3 menos 3 que
multiplica a xy menos 3 que multiplica a
7 menos 3 x menos 21 y bueno los padres
de este asunto es que x + 7 y x + 7 es
de nuevo nuestro factor común y por lo
tanto lo podemos
factorizar recuerdas cómo se llamaba
esto esto es la famosísima factorización
por agrupación ya tenemos ahora aquí un
grupo un binomio en lo cual smith factor
común y lo voy a factorizar de nuevo
para que quede multiplicando a otro
binomio aquí el binomio pues el binomio
4x menos 3 así que déjenme escribirlo de
esta manera esto lo voy a borrar porque
me queda más x menos me da menos 3 y
simple y sencillamente me va a quedar x
+ 7
déjame escribirlo aquí está x + 7 que es
el factor común que va a multiplicar a
4x menos 3 que son los otros dos
monumentos que están multiplicando
precisamente a este x más 7 x más 7 que
multiplica a 4 x menos 34 x menos este 3
me da 4 x menos 3 y que creen ya
encontré la solución de la factorización
de esta expresión cuadrática que tenía
aquí arriba que se veía bastante
horrible gracias a la factorización por
agrupación por lo tanto yo sé que esto
es bastante confuso en un principio y
mejor vamos a trabajar en un segundo
el segundo ejemplo que me quiero tomar
es este 6 x cuadrada + 7 x + 1 y bueno
como factor hizo esta expresión lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es buscar
dos números tales que aportes sea 1 por
6 ó 6 por 1 lo cual me da 6 y más b sea
el término el coeficiente que está al
lado de la x es decir 7 y bueno aquellos
números cuando yo 2 multiplicó me dan 6
y cuando yo lo sumo me dan 7 pues está
muy fácil es 1 y 6 tiene que ser igual a
1 y b tiene que ser igual a 6 o mejor
describe esta manera esto es lo mismo
que 1 y 6 y por lo tanto yo me tengo que
fijar ahora que 7x lo puedo escribir
como 6 x + 1 x 6 x mas x pero que es más
parecido a 6 x cuadrada a 6 x 1 x pues
te vas a dar cuenta que es mucho más
parecido a 6 x por lo tanto lo voy a
poner en un principio 6 x cuadrada más 6
x más 1 x y que eran más parecidos 1 x 6
x 1 y tú me vas a decir que es más
parecido 1 x
ya queda todo en orden 6x cuadrada más 6
x + 1 x + 1 y entonces como los dos
primeros recuerda siempre hay que tomar
los dos primeros términos y factorizar
lo más que se pueda que por cierto es 6
x 6 x que multiplica a x + 16 x x x me
da 6 x cuadrado y 6 x x 1 me da 6 x y de
los otros dos términos tengo que
factorizar lo más que se pueda pero si
te das cuenta lo más que se puede de
aquí es 11 que multiplica a x + 1 y
entonces si esto tiene factorización te
tienes que quedar un factor común en
este paso es decir tenemos que encontrar
un grupo o un binomio que sea tu factor
común para terminar de utilizar la
famosísima factorización por agrupación
y aquí pues si lo tenemos tenemos que x
+ 1 es de nuevo nuestro factor común y
entonces me va a quedar x + 1 que
multiplica a 6x por una parte y por otra
parte a 1 y ya otra vez
obtuve mi resultado gracias a la
factorización por agrupación obtuve como
factorizar esta expresión de aquí arriba
que no se veía tan fácil factorizar en
un principio
pero seguramente te estás preguntando de
dónde viene todo esto así que vamos a
hacer el caso general para entender
perfectamente de dónde viene todo esto a
x + b no esperen los parientes que la a
la b y la c no quiero que te confundas
con la clave que tenemos aquí arriba por
lo tanto déjeme escribirlo
de una manera distinta quiero ver qué es
lo que pasa con fx más que no te asustes
solamente me estoy tomando otro par de
letras esto que a su vez multiplican a h
x + j mascota porque la i se utiliza
para otras cosas que ya veremos en
vídeos posteriores y bueno pues vamos a
multiplicar que me queda de todo esto
fx por h x me queda f h x cuadrada
efe h x cuadrada y después me queda f x
que multiplica a jota me queda fj x y
después de es que por h x es g h x
x y después que por jota me queda g j
gj perfecto y ahora voy a actualizar
estos dos términos que están en medio me
va a quedar lo siguiente fh x cuadrada
más y ahora sí voy a contar estos 2 fj
más g h que multiplica a x pj más g h y
todo esto multiplica x ya esto le
sumamos más que jota y bueno realmente
cómo resolvemos este tipo de ejercicios
si nos fijamos acá arriba y buscábamos
dos números tales que multiplicados me
dieran 6 por 1 y sumados me dieran 7 es
decir el término que está al lado de la
equis y éstas cuentan aquí el término
que este lado de la x es
efe/j más que h entonces qué te parece
si definimos así lo siguiente voy a
definir que a es igual a f j&b es igual
a g h entonces a más b que multiplica x
es lo mismo que el pj más que h que
multiplica x y entonces ya tenemos lo de
arriba y ahora vamos a ver cuánto es
a volver es lo mismo que fj el cj que
multiplica a g h y esto lo podemos
ordenar de una manera distinta porque
recuerda que el orden de los factores no
afecta el producto cuando hablamos de
números reales y lo voy a poner como fh
que multiplica a gj lo único que estoy
haciendo es utilizando la propiedad
conmutativa de la multiplicación y bueno
esto lo puedo ver como fh que multiplica
a su vez a g jota y quien es esto si te
das cuenta es el primer término que
teníamos aquí el que estaba
multiplicando a equis cuadrada y el
último término que tengo aquí el que
está como coeficiente libre como término
libre y entonces ya llegamos a lo que
queríamos es justo por esta razón que
está funcionando nuestra factorización
por agrupación porque buscamos dos
números que multiplicados me den el
primer término y el último término y que
a su vez sumados me den el término que
está al lado de la equis así que vamos a
hacer en esta ocasión un ejercicio un
poco más difícil y no quiero que te
espantes de hecho tal vez lo veas y
digas en este ejercicio demasiado obvio
es muy fácil resolverlo pero quiero
aumentarle un poquito de nivel
ejercicio aunque tal vez en un futuro
haga un vídeo de solamente ejercicios de
este estilo vamos a ver el siguiente
caso se me ocurre ponerte
- x ubican ya esto le voy a sumar 17 x
cuadrada y después le voy a quitar menos
70 x y seguramente la primera procede si
eres oye salió no tengo ni idea de cómo
resolver este este polinomio porque si
te das cuenta no es un polinomio cuadra
tico es un polinomio cúbico pero lo
primero que quiero que veas es que todo
es divisible entre x por lo tanto
podemos sacar como factor común a equis
o mejor a menos x - x va a ser factor
común y entonces menos equis pública
entre menos x me da es cuadrada positiva
después 17 que es cuadrada entre menos x
me da menos 17 x y después me queda
menos 70 x entre menos x me da más 70 y
ahora que ya tenemos factor izada la
menos equis vamos a fijarnos en lo que
está dentro del paréntesis si te das
cuenta lo que está dentro del paréntesis
es así es una ecuación cuadrática y
vamos a ver si la podemos factorizar
buscamos dos números que multiplicados
me den 70 positivo y que sumados media
en menos 17 y eso está muy fácil
seguramente se te ocurre que es menos
7 y en efecto es menos diez y menos
siete porque menos diez por menos siete
me da más setenta positivo y menos diez
menos siete me da menos 17 x por lo
tanto se lo podemos escribir como x
menos 10 que multiplica a x menos 7 y
todo esto por menos x que era la menos x
del principio que egresó ya factor
izamos esta expresión que era cúbica y
además que decías que no estaba tan
fácil de factorizar realmente no fue tan
difícil pero bueno en fin realmente lo
que quiero que veas y lo que quería
enseñarte en este vídeo era esa
factorizar expresiones de este estilo
donde no tenemos al lado de la equis
cuadrada un 1 como siempre habíamos
visto tenemos otra cosa y ahora ya sabes
factorizar lo en un tiempo no muy largo